each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
welcome again everybody I hope you had a
very nice evening last night after the
incredibly exciting sessions we have
yesterday so today we are going to have
the UPC IC workshop this is what
Microsoft calls the third day event
after the faculty summit and oftentimes
that happens during the faculty summit
is people just have these short times to
present general directions of research
so this session is so that we can take
deeper dives into the topics and we work
with a Illinois Intel a Microsoft to get
this this program ready and we are going
to go in a set them in the faculty
summit just on presentations by the
partners we decided to go by team so the
teams are programming systems tools for
parallel testing and debugging
applications architecture and at the end
like yesterday will have another panel
that we hope is going to be as excited
as the one we had yesterday and the
panel is going to be UPC LC can industry
and academia collaborations be effective
we hope that there will be a lot of
discussion debate and we hope we can
have read conclusions so a few remarks
if you want to connect to the to
externally through wireless there is a
username and a password out there and we
have buses going back to the hyatt hotel
starting at five and probably last bus
is going to be about 5 30 so once we
finish the panel we just have to go out
and rush for the bus if you could please
Sign you have not done that sign a deed
at the door so that we know who is
coming and the affiliations and your
names and with that I like to introduce
our first speaker David Padua he comes
from anniversary of Illinois where he
has been since 1985 and when when I do
these presentations is always difficult
to omit some of the remarks because
everybody who is talking today has such
a distinguished career
that I struggled to find what to say
during less than one minute so that we
can spend most of the time listening to
them so david has been a professor in
Illinois since 1985 he's he has a very
distinguished career and probably the
last book you wrote easy encyclopedia on
parallel computing and I don't want to
say more because we know pretty much
very well his great accomplishments and
David is going to talk about abstraction
for a parallel program thanks of course
the last book I wrote I didn't write
because it wasn't a single opinion
that's a and that was a very pleasant
experience in the Cecropia many people
contributed was very moving to see how
much people were willing to to to to
participate in that project okay so i
was asked by my colleagues to give you a
summary of the work going on at illinois
does a very difficult task so they were
we going on you know in the area of
compilers and languages so i'll try to
do my best but first i must say that
what i'm going to say is not
comprehensive neither in terms of the
projects known in terms of her people so
there are more people do a co-pilot
there are more co pilot projects as
going on boat I'll mentioned a few that
seem more relevant to to this this
meeting so mainly I will focus on the
work of be cannot base way me who's on
my research group and will be
presentations on compilers and and the
language there
that will be in design so let me start
by saying some common places about what
the problem is so as we know parallelism
is everywhere and if parallel ism is
going to succeed it will be that because
a software will be developed rather can
take advantage of parallelism okay but
when that happens and if that happens
one of the things that obviously is
going to happen is that there will be a
deep in productivity because writing
parallel products is for complex and
write this equation prawns you need to
deal with a performance scalability
there are new sources of defects and so
on so forth okay so what we face as a
challenges over people it's a facilitate
parallel programming reduce the impact
of parallelism on productivity is not
very glamorous but is truth as though
all we're trying to reduce the impact
try to bring back productivity to the
level of the sequential either up and we
find you a lot of challenge what of
course optimization because performance
is a crucial in the parallel Rihanna
because only through a scalability new
machine through the scalability of
software new machines will be valuable
and people willing to widen so it's a
business model there is the issue of
portability that is also tremendously
difficult with cosa while porting across
machines in the sequential hira was a
relatively straightforward because the
difference was in the type of
instructions and they perhaps a few
classes of instruction in the case of
parallelism the classes of machine can
differ why this is a big difference
between a GPU and a collection of CPUs
and there is a big difference between
vector processing and distributed memory
machines and so on so there is a there
is a tremendous issue there so that's a
problem
has never been resolved and we really
don't have a good answer how to
guarantee that you write the code that
will be executable on a variety of
classes of machines deceit and memory
shared memory arrays oh and the old
challenge of course is correctness there
are new classes of the effects non
determinacy dead blocks and you know
other issues related to to parallelize
so how do addresses challenge from what
I have seen there are mainly two
strategies that I will leave a viable to
address the problem one is to raise the
level of programming so that you have
enough information to be able to map
across machines that will facilitate
portability you have enough information
to the optimization that will solve the
problem of getting good performance and
scalability and so on so forth and that
of course is a is a difficult problem
because at what level you present the
language you say say say it's not an
easy easy issue you may want to work at
the level of the application and half
abstractions that represent complete
applications or you can have
abstractions that represent algorithms
or you can have abstractions that
represent katniss which ones are useful
how you combine them is AC is not a
problem that is easy to solve so you
there are a number of possibilities you
can work from the formula level or the
very general description level you can
have domain-specific languages you can
have very high level operators and you
can have just plain parallel
abstractions like parallel loops and
coving Inco ain't that something tell us
one and the other which i think is also
crucial although although many people
don't seem to to be fun of fan of these
approaches is to have techniques that
automate the process
of optimization automate the process of
porting and so on so forth so we
actually need to work on this aerial
photo tuners compilers so on and so
forth so so so so so you know and I
maybe I did this a couple of days are
long but I think in our dog maybe I'm
missing something but I think certainly
these are two of the main strategies
that we can use to to address the
problem of productivity in the parallel
world so let me let me start by by going
quickly over what is being done at
Illinois and I hope it's not too boring
will be just a short description of
projects so three projects in the
language rearm 30 lane that's good when
may whose group this HT a quirk that we
have been doing my group and the Hydra
thing I describe this is very quickly to
you so trioli is a is a library both
building functions that you can use from
basically here is a an example is a
basically a library that you can call
from from Python codes and I think this
work is similar gets to the world that
is going to be describing the talk after
after this one basically has a number of
operators with iterators and and the
idea is that the operators are
implemented in parallel and you can work
in the in the programming at the high
level using a conventional notation so
they then notation is Python and I think
that's a
that's all I am able to say about this
they are working on compilation
techniques and so on and they continue
working in this area this is the work as
I was saying of when Mako and he's a
student Christopher Rodriguez hi that's
one project and and they here as you can
see the goal is to raise the level of
trying to have functions that implement
operations and you encapsulate the
parallelism within the functions the
other related approach is the one in my
group on hierarchically Tyler race and
this is work that my students colleagues
and I have worked for for a few years
and basically the main idea aside you
sep descried yesterday's that we
recognize the importance of blocking and
tidiness a first cluster all yet if you
look at the algorithms or parallel
computing sequential algorithm dealing
with locality they the tiles appear over
and over again a second toss a constant
so so so having them in the language
explicity we thought was a was a was a
good idea reality this started when we
had the hpcs program as started by by by
DARPA and the IBM guys wanted an
extension to matlab the fall for
parallel programming and by looking at
matlab i decided that they some of the
structures they have this i know i
forgot the name they have some classes
of objects that basically are
collections of of arrays and enable a
hierarchy of tiles i thought that that
could be used to represent parallelism
the idea is a relatively simple you have
a raised at our ties and the task can be
tired and so on then you can use the
tiles at the top 44
distribution across machines they ties
within the tiles for locality are
different levels you can use the tiles
at the second level for shared memory
parallel lives and so on so forth so
it's a it's a natural thing in the
hierarchical machines of today and then
we have worked more recently in
extending this notion to regular data
structures like Satan and so on so so
here they the operations are on a race
and sets and the ideas that the racer
Thailand you can represent by
manipulating these objects parallel
computations that's basically daily I am
personally still struggling with a
notion of wha what primitive you need to
go beyond linear algebra and also
struggling with the problems do we need
to go beyond linear al you you can do
everything with radio repair hubs so so
so that's an issue that I don't think I
cannot say but but but I can say is that
our work on only regular structures
proved to be very very effectively there
is a tremendous complication in tiling
not regularly structure because you need
mechanisms to decide where each
component of the set will go and we can
make those mechanisms but it's not
obvious how to build improved from a
sketch you need to to to think very hard
so the end result with this notation of
course is that you can get codes that
are much more compact and more
importantly more readable than than the
equivalent MPI codes so so and the other
advantage of this approach of having all
your computation with a parallelism
encapsulated in sight operations on this
race is that you have portable programs
you can implement the operations as such
if you Colonels you can implement them
as a threads within MPL you can
implement them as parallel loops and
they in all cases we have tested they
work
reasonably well all right so that's that
and then the other project that I just
wanted to mention briefly another
whining in our group is called hider and
that is with my students Alexander Lucia
tone and a colleague from the narrative
or dough the neighbor too and the idea
here is a to start with a formula and
for example you want to find X in that
equation and then what we do is with
tile the different operators and convert
the equation into multiple equations and
looking for a recursion so eventually
this reduces if you want to go all the
way to a scalar equation that this is it
to solve ok so so in the process of
decomposing the the equation what you
find is a number of operations that can
be executed in parallel and by doing the
the composition what you build is a
graph of operations that can be executed
in parallel ok the great advantage of
this approach is that you can partition
the components in multiple ways and that
enables you to search the space of
possible solutions and look for a good
performing version of a of a of the
algorithm we have a still the
preliminary stages but what we have seen
is that they the the calls that result
are very good and competitive with what
people have written by hand so stay
tuned there will be more about this in
the in the future ok next project is a
about compiler evaluation this is a
topic that i think is tremendously
important because while you see a lot of
publications about new compiler
techniques and strategies and so on what
you don't see too much is a evaluation
of what exists out there and compiler
technology is not just about algorithms
it's not just about ideas is about how
well our algorithm
when applied to real programs so is a
tremendously difficult problem to
evaluation of compilers not so much for
the conceptual issues but the labor in
Bor because you need really to do manual
analysis of what is happening to really
understand how well the compiler is
working so here is a project that we did
for the for two years at Illinois the
evaluation of how to vectorization so so
what happened is the blue waters project
it is the block water's probably idea is
to program the machine with mpi calls
but but they thread within him they they
the MPI program has to execute as
efficiently as possible and what they
want to automate the process of tuning
for vector AC 444444 to take advantage
of the vector extensions of the
microprocessor brain power 7 machine at
the time so they asked me to work with
the IBM compiler people to make sure
that I deliver a compiler for the blue
waters that will produce a good good
performance especially in the context of
taking advantage of the vector
extensions so so is this is a regarding
team Matson's coming yesterday so it's a
in reality this is a form of how to
parallelization and of course the issue
is not whether it is impossible or not
is a matter of degree because typically
what people do is around they're prone
to the compiler and whenever you can
find vector extensions they just a
reflektor operator they profit from that
and benefits for that and in reality is
a very important technology so much so
that all compiler self to vectorize and
the compiler groups invest a lot of time
in this technology for many reasons one
of them of course is that you are
already compiler you have machines by
how well they perform on expect codes
and if the compilers do better at
vectorized the machine looks better so
so there is a what
is also in a real relationship of our
toe vectorization to regular users all
over the world auto parallelization I
think ISA it's also true that all
compilers auto paralyzed but when you
talk to the IBM compiler people they say
they hear very little about users of
auto paralyzation bottle to
vectorization ISA is a is a widely use
and of course why not you can have
computers that answer all sort of
questions no reason why a computer
cannot answer out of vectorization
places cut this loop vectorize so let me
just tell you briefly they the outcome
of the of the of the evaluation and
briefly what we are doing going forward
so basically we look at we took the the
collection of loops that David Callahan
and don't gather and we whine put
together 20 years ago and ran them
through three compilers GCC ICC and the
IBM compiler and what we found out is
that there was a great variability in
the ending what the compilers were able
to do and despite the fact that at some
point we gave the benchmarks and the
results to the different compiler groups
still after a while they and the
compilers kept evolving because of that
after a while you can still see that
they were loops that were vectorized by
some compilers and not by the others and
with no good reason for that so
basically I think the most important
lesson I learned is that we have
tremendous difficulty figuring out how
to do quality control in compiler
development so that's that's that to me
the biggest reason because when we look
at the loops there is no reason why they
cannot be vectorized we have the
technology we have the mechanisms to a
transformation to do the analysis the
only problem is that the compiler just
doesn't know how to take all these tools
and put them together and and do the
good day
appropriate thing for a particular job
it doesn't know how to seek shaded boxes
mean the two and the three no no other
thought of that right oh you're icc you
have a box of the three and then GCC box
42 I to tell you i don't remember right
now there is a paper in a pot last year
and they describe all the old AV page
there I they state they inter compile
well okay is this dot the end of the
story this is only the loops that were
very simple when you when we talk the
real applications all the compilers
behave equally bubbly yeah thirty
percent of the loops were vectorize
performance when you did the work by
hand as if you were compared you can get
factors of two or more performance
improvement overall so so there is a lot
to but in all cases real applications
and not when you look at the
transformation that you need to apply
they are there we know the applique the
transformations there is nothing new
that there needs to be learn about
analysis of our transformation what we
need to learn is how to guide the the
compiler how to establish a path to take
the code from a hole in uniform to a
phone that performs well if you just
launched a compiler and say search if
there were no tomorrow then we will get
good performance for sure the products
compilers most be efficient or so they
cannot take a long time to compile and
just part of the reason and you're on
the problem of optimization is a black
art nobody knows exactly how to to to
search these people the hidden
immediately yes what programming
language are they see
your analysis was their foreign language
perspective they are legal fertilized
person and in fact uh a all these are
the effects of their or lack of
effectiveness of the compiler was after
restrict and a lion keywords where a
play where inserted by hand so even then
you do I liked it tree of colors if you
are interested in vectorization reading
that original paper by David and Jachin
and so on would be worthwhile I mean
just just to see what can be vectorized
test to discover yeah it's interesting
paper it's already there anyway and when
you look at that you also read this one
and you one thing a site did is compare
the effectiveness of vectorizing
co-pilots dang and now and they are not
better now thus we will see ah so then
the next we have 40 minutes right so
have okay so let me just 30 minutes okay
so let me very briefly described in two
minutes what is going on earth is going
on so there is of course compiling
opencl and i'll tell you one is up a
translator developed by when me whose
group that transformed opencl depending
on the target machine for vector
multi-threading sequential and so on and
it's a very effective as you can see
here and they are still working on that
then there is work also by whammy huon
de italia out system that reorganizes
structures of array of structures into
tile information and also very effective
mechanism to reorganize the data visa
this is an area of great importance to
able to restructure the data to to get
good performance and then finally we did
some work on tiling an overlap tiling
and hierarchically overlap tiling that
was very important for certain classes
of application we are now working on n
dimensional tiling an overlap of using
this tightly to overlap communication
with computation with some successful
and then finally the other project and
you self described this yesterday say
they work on deterministic parallel Java
and basically as you know the idea is to
insert declarations in the program and
have the compiler in fair what regions
of the data are being modified by the
different threats in the in the program
and determine whether or not the problem
will be deterministic or not let me just
say there are novel features of DPJ not
available before for example the
availability of nested regions which is
very important with your Travis in our
trees for example and they support for a
race-based computation which of course
is crucial and I'm going to skip this
the other thing important they did is
they allow for non determinacy the so
you can have non deterministic programs
non determinate programs and check still
for the absence of races so so they are
sure that the data that conflict is in
close within anatomica within a critical
region okay so that's does that so
program assistant for parihar STV worry
there is a lot to the truth is that the
product has proved more complex than we
expected him along all dimension but
much problem has been made and will keep
keep working aretha we prov course will
never solve it completely what the
current situation is a spot attic so we
need to to do much more thanks
select embedding justice on Just In Time
specializations and this is the main pet
the UC Berkeley has been working on as
you know and sharp is gathering from
Berkeley and is taking a postdoc at MIT
direction yes that's right and if you
please repeat the question because we
are taping representations thank you so
I was told to make sure it's the right
resolution ok so I'm Schaub Camille I'm
from UC Berkeley where I've been a grad
student for a few years and I'm going to
be giving some updates on seats which is
selectively embedded just-in-time
specialization this is our technology
for enabling high performance from
high-level languages and it was really
good to see some of the stuff that
Professor padua just talked about
because one it looks like there are
other people doing similar things and to
the motivation was all there so
vectorizing is arguably the easiest form
of auto parallelism but and the
technology to to auto vectorize is known
but it looks like it requires somebody
to guide the use of that technology and
that's kind of the the approach we've
taken so just to remind you what
selective embedded just-in-time
specialization or C Jets looks like you
we want people to be able to write in
these productivity languages like Python
so their application has portions that
just run on the interpreter and use the
normal Python infrastructure but there
are other portions of the program
which passed through domain-specific
embedded language compilers and these
compilers use the infrastructure we've
built which is called ASP to intercept
these calls and translate that the
function in question into a low-level
language that translated function is
then compiled and dynamically loaded
into the interpreter which then calls
that function and returns the result to
the user so all of this looks like from
the user perspective that they're
writing in Python but what's really
happening is that portions of that
Python code are being translated into C
or C++ or CUDA or other low-level
parallel language compiled and run and
the result returned we also introduce
caching so that this just-in-time
compilation doesn't have to happen all
the time only the first time something
is run so here is an example of an
actual a kernel that we can specialize
using the stencil domain-specific
embedded language if you look it looks
just like Python code if you're familiar
with Python lots of colons and
indentation but what this computation is
basically saying is for each of the
interior points in a multi-dimensional
grid for each of the neighbors of that
point apply this particular function so
we treat this kind of like a declarative
specification of the computation so even
though it looks like a you know usual
imperative programming with a 4 and so
on all this is actually doing is telling
the infrastructure what the computation
is not how to do the computation in
particular there are certain constructs
here that are domain-specific so the
first thing is that we inherit from a
particular class this is what tells the
infrastructure that this computation is
something that needs to be specialized
so the initializer for this stencil
colonel
class is the thing that you know looks
at the source code and does all the
steps that I'm going to describe in a
minute we also have these special
iterators which are used in the program
translation so the first step is to
introspect this function and get the
abstract syntax tree this is done
mechanically automatically using Python
infrastructure we didn't have to really
implement anything for this right Python
can introspect itself so you get this
syntax tree that represents the
computation if you look closely you'll
see there's a function definition and
there's these four loops and you know
lots of other nodes so we use that that
ast and do a mechanical translation to a
domain-specific intermediate
representation so there's some effort
required for the person writing the
domain-specific invented language
compiler to write this translation be
from that Python ast into this
intermediate representation now the
intermediate representation looks like a
tree it has some domain-specific
constructs but again what it really is
representing is not how to do a
computation but actually the declarative
specification of what that computation
is this is done in our infrastructure by
writing simple tree transformation rules
that work on local pieces of the tree it
uses our infrastructure and the visitor
pattern to make it as easy as possible
to define the point of this translation
is once you get to this point we can run
correctness checks we can ensure that
you know because it's a declarative we
can do things like make sure that the
specification is correct by construction
as in when we're translating it we make
sure that everything we're translating
is going to result in a correct
specification so
if not all of the checking is done in
this portion of the compilers so from
there depending on the target machine or
what the the actual code is running on
it is translated into a back-end domain
a back-end general AST so an AST in c++
or in cuda with parallel constructs etc
etc and then that that tree is then
optimized now this is where most of the
domain-specific knowledge is used or the
expert programming knowledge is used so
in this process you know you figure out
well for this particular construct I
translated into this kind of C++ and I
know that I can do certain optimizations
on this as Professor Padua pointed out
there's often cases where the user who
is writing the code knows that a
particular transformation is correct
however the compiler does not have the
absolute knowledge in order to know that
common example is things like loop
unrolling now certain cases the part the
compiler can prove that this is a
correct transformation but though that's
not in every case in which it would be
correct in this particular example you
know I'm an expert in stencil
computations I come from the
high-performance computing world so I
know how to do this I know how to make a
stencil computation go fast so all of my
knowledge is embedded into you know
optimizing this trip we've also
implemented many of the common compiler
optimizations things like Luke blocking
loop and rolling these are things that
are part of our infrastructure so are
you just need to apply them in the
proper way so what does the code kind of
look like well you end up with a very so
this is actually a very simple example
of what comes out of the code I just
showed you and this is a simp
example in that you know it's 2d it only
has a couple optimizations applied so
just so you don't have to squint there's
parallelization here there is cash
blocking which ensures that you work you
work on a working set sized cache block
at a time and there is loop unrolling or
register blocking which helps expose
things like vectorize ability it also
helps you know expose things like common
sub-expression elimination and so on so
this is the code that gets passed to the
compiler and as a bunch of the auto
tuning work has shown if you write your
code in a particular way you can get the
compiler to to give you much better
performance than writing your code in
the most naive way so that's that's what
we're doing here I've left out a couple
of the major pieces of what see jets
does vary for example i just mentioned
auto tuning I haven't shown you any of
that but basically we generate many
different versions and on each
invocation of a function we run a
different version until we've explored
the space completely and then we use the
best version for subsequent invitations
so this is see jets for the rest of my
time I'm going to give some updates on
the current domain-specific invented
languages and libraries we have show you
some new results some users and upcoming
releases and finally talk a bit about
some future directions and what we're
doing so first off these this is kind of
the the set of implemented
domain-specific embedded languages and
libraries that we have the the red ones
i'll give you some more detail about but
let me talk briefly about a few of these
the platforms we target range from you
know x86 plus openmp to
mpi to cuda to sell plus so we have
basically every backend we even have a
cloud back-end at this point I want to
just let me just briefly describe each
one so the first one is is for stencil
or structured grid computations I'll
spend some time talking about some
results from that the second one is for
graph algorithms and I'll spend some
time talking about about that as well
we've also implemented a simple parallel
map domain-specific language which
basically lets you compose these
languages with map so you can do high
level parallelism there one of the big
success stories i would say is the
gaussian mixture modeling library we
have which has been released i'll talk a
bit about the infrastructure that's that
that's a part of but you know that's
able to get performance that's 250 x
real-time faster than what the domain
scientists were using before which was
handwritten hand optimized cuda we're
also we also have a matrix powers
communication avoiding library which
i'll talk a bit about and we have three
new domain specific embedded languages
that are under development right now so
the first one is for the bag of little
bootstraps algorithm which is a
statistical analysis tool and this one
is used by people who want to evaluate
machine learning and other kinds of
things we have a version that can target
silk plus on local multi-core machine as
well as a version that can run on top of
the spark infrastructure in the cloud so
that's under development we also are
working with the people who make
GraphLab which is a c++ parallel library
for machine learning using the graph
representation we're working with them
to replace their current API their
current API
does something quite convoluted so it
first they created a java api for their
c++ then they used j Python or Jai thon
to write a Python API on top of the Java
API on top of the C++ API so we're
getting rid of all of those layers and
we're using our infrastructure to
replace the current API so that you can
get C++ level performance while writing
in Python for your graph algorithms and
finally we are working on a
communication avoiding parallel
recursive structural pattern so what
this comes from is the insight that
there's lots of algorithms that have a
particular recursive structure and this
particular recursive structure allows
you to choose at any point whether you
want to run the different leaf nodes of
the computation in parallel or whether
you want to run them see really
depending on the available resources so
a preliminary implementation of this was
applied to matrix multiply just you know
the standard thing that has been
optimized the hell out of but we were
actually able to beat MKL Intel's math
kernal libraries using this particular
recursive structure now we're using m KL
by using m KL but being more intelligent
about when to do things in parallel and
when not to do things in parallel so
first let me talk a bit about
performance that we're getting out of
the stencil domain-specific embedded
language this is a set of benchmark
kernels on the x-axis on the y-axis is
the fraction of peak performance the
last set of bars is the geometric mean
and we're comparing against pawar which
is the state-of-the-art domain-specific
language for stencils using silk plus
it's developed by MIT and it gets
excellent performance
using the cache oblivious algorithm so
we are able to get a geometric mean of
ninety-three percent of peak performance
and this peak performance comes from
looking at the kernels and finding out
that they are bound by the memory
bandwidth performance of the machine and
ninety-three percent of peak performance
is is quite a bit better than you could
get in Python just as a order of
magnitude kind of thing each of these is
about two to three thousand times faster
than what you would get by writing it in
Python so this is a single node for core
i7 machine we compared to the auto
paralyzer in GCC which uses the
polyhedral framework and we're able to
outperform that by up to 11 X and about
two and a half x faster than pawar and
as I said the geometric mean here is
ninety-three percent of attainable peak
yes that's right
sir the question was this is the first
comparison that Robert has seen on the
same hardware for posh waar and and our
infrastructure so I mentioned the
communication avoid start language like
the difference is that they generally
official did this envoy there
well so the different the question was
the difference is not due to language
whether the differences due to language
or whether it is because they're using a
cache oblivious algorithm and we're
using a cache aware algorithm well I
think the difference is well it's
certainly not due to language we're both
using C++ we're both using the Intel
compiler but the difference is due
perhaps somewhat to the use of cache
oblivious algorithm versus cache aware
algorithm but I think it's more so that
because we're doing our compilation just
in time we we have to us available every
parameter that you would possibly in
line into the computation so we know the
sizes which tells us what kind of
blockings are valid and we explicitly
generate all the valid blockings and
i'll use auto tuning so I would say it's
probably more related to our use of
auto-tuning than it is you to the to the
algorithm because conceptually if you
look at the algorithms they do the same
thing however because we can use auto
tuning we're able to get the fastest
possible performance from a wide variety
of code variants
so so the question is they have in a way
to add auto-tuning to their process is
that a statement or are you asking me oh
so I I am not aware of this
functionality when I presented this in
front of the push war people they they
think they can improve their performance
and you know where I'm sharing the code
with them so hopefully we can figure out
how to make their performance better so
the other thing I wanted to talk about
in terms of performance results is that
we've talked a bit about our
communication avoiding matrix powers
library and what this particular Colonel
does is it's a building block of
communication avoiding curl of subspace
methods and what this chart shows is the
performance of three different
implementations of a communication of
waiting cg solve I'm sorry three
different implementations of a CG solves
one of which is communication avoiding
so the first one is kind of the standard
the blue is the standard CG that you
would get if you're writing in Python
and using a good performance library
it's a scifi which basically implements
all of the matlab functionality in
python it's what most people use when
they're doing this kind of computation
in Python the red is using Intel's MKL
and the yellow is our communication
avoiding CG with matrix powers only
doing one matrix multiplication at a
time so this is kind of the baseline
that you can compare with the non
communication of wedding stuff and the
green is communication avoiding CG using
our matrix powers Colonel the dark
bottom parts of the bars are the time
spent in the matrix powers portion of
the CG solve and the I'm sorry the
matrix multiplication
part of the CG soul and the light bars
are the rest of the computation what
this really is showing is that if you
look at just the matrix powers part
we're able to outperform Intel's m KL by
2x which results in much faster solves
so I want to talk a bit about some new
work that we've been doing in
collaboration with people from UC Santa
Barbara and we've been working with a
Python infrastructure that they've built
called the knowledge discovery tool box
and the knowledge discovery tool box is
basically a high level graph algorithms
library for domain scientists so most
people will use the you know k dt to
write their to run their graph
algorithms do things like breadth-first
search or you know clustering and things
like that it's built on top of the
combinatorial applause which is a low
level c++ with MPI library that casts
graph algorithms as linear algebra
operations and that you know uses MPI
and can use OpenMP silk and things like
that the this is not yet implemented
that's why it's in a dotted line so
we're adding in the siege its
infrastructure here to bridge the
performance gap between things that are
written by domain scientists and things
that are written by people at the
low-level distributed combinatorial
blouse an example of this is a
domain-specific embedded language for
filtering now oftentimes you have a
graph that has attributes on the edges
or the vertices but you want to perform
your graph algorithm only on a subset of
this graph so for example you have phone
calls and texts and you only care about
performing your graph algorithm on the
phone calls so what we've done is we've
implemented a domain-specific embedded
language that allows you to write
filters
and the filters are basically functions
that return true if this edge should be
included and false if it should not k dt
itself has infrastructure for doing
these filters but in k dt the filters
are written in python and at each edge
during the graph algorithm it has to up
call into Python and decide whether this
particular edge should be included or
not so that incurs a pretty big
performance penalty so our domain
specific embedded language looks just
you know uses Python it uses the same
kind of infrastructure to write that
here's an example of a filter that
checks you know if the count is greater
than zero or and if the time is less
than some particular time you've passed
in and these are edge after means of the
of the graph so using this we can speed
up the performance quite a bit so here's
a graph that shows the mean BFS time on
a log scale on the left side and on the
x-axis is filter permeability that's the
percentage of edges that pass the filter
the performance that you should be
comparing is the green which is KD T's
current implementation that like I said
runs in Python and the blue which is the
one that uses seeds now in order to
build a baseline for this we also
implemented the same thing at the low
level C++ library just to compare now
this isn't something that you know we
would expect a domain scientist to be
able to do because it involves writing
low-level C++ parallel code but that
gives a good baseline in any case the
performance here is five times faster
than then the current k dt and the slow
down versus writing the whole thing in
c++ is twenty-five to fifty percent what
I'm showing here is performance on a on
36 cores of a 40 core xeon for socket
machine we've also run this on in the
distributed setting on hopper at
at nurse which is a large-scale AMD I'm
sorry it's a large-scale cray xe6 using
AMD processors and we've seen similar
results there so I'm going to switch in
in the last few minutes i have here and
talk a bit about what's going on with
users and and and so on so we've had
over a thousand downloads of our asp
infrastructure from from the python
package index which is kind of the the
mechanism for distributing python
packages the k dt work i showed you is
going to be integrated into mainline k
dt and released this year this is going
to be you know kind of the first major
outside users releasing something using
our infrastructure and the goal is that
the second de sel we've implemented
there which i haven't really talked
about is also going to be part of the
release after that in the first two
weeks after the gaussian mixture model
library was released at a at the ACM
multimedia conference we had over 800
downloads of of that library and we have
outside users at Carnegie Mellon and
other places that are using this in
production to replace their current C++
code yesterday Timmon matson showed some
numbers on an application which does
protein docking this was an application
that was ported by Henry gab who was at
Intel at the time and it gets 290 x
speed up by running in the cloud without
any change to the ported application and
finally Tim's also developing a FFT
specialized ER and giving us great
feedback on things we need to work on in
terms of usability and in terms of
making it easy for people to develop
these domain-specific embedded languages
and auto-tuning libraries
Python so some future work so right now
the the auto tuning and the results I've
showed you is kind of doing the most
naive auto-tuning which looks at all the
particular versions and just runs them
in some kind of random order so we think
by adding machine learning and we have
some evidence of this we can get much
faster searches that converge on the
optimal version so there's there was a
paper by archana ganapati in Koscheck
dada a couple years back for stencils
that shows that machine learning can
greatly improve the speed of converging
on the best version so we want to
integrate that kind of search into our
infrastructure and make it easy for
other people to use in their specialized
errs in their domain specific embedded
languages some of the ideas from C Jets
are also finding their way into hardware
prototyping i think krista is going to
talk about that later on today and we're
also exploring one of the big problems
in using these which is composition and
one of the directions we've seen is that
pattern based frameworks that are used
for a particular kind of computation or
a particular class of programs such as
multimedia programs or or other things
like that is a good test bed for
bringing composition to these
domain-specific invented languages so
there's some work from from Berkeley
that's also going to be talked about
later today called pike ASP which is
building a infrastructure for doing
multimedia application multimedia
applications in Python and get fast
performance from that so it consists of
a bunch of library components some
customizable components and structural
patterns that you can put together in
different ways to build your application
there's going to be a whole talk on that
later today so you'll hear much more
about that so too
conclude we've seen really high
performance in kernels we've seen
examples of applications authored by
people at Berkeley and also people
outside of Berkeley that are using this
infrastructure to build real real
applications we're doing some work on
prop on composition and we think that
this infrastructure and ideas from it
are really critical for enabling agile
hardware software co design and export
design space explorations thank you lots
of acknowledgments because there's lots
of people worked on who where does
if there's a weapon yes on your previous
answer the performance is that okay the
law of sensitivity studies on how much
you
yes and I can show you a graph offline
yes so the question was do you have
sensitivity sensitivity studies on how
much performance you gain by using auto
tuning and I I certainly do it's in my
thesis so I can show you agree
that's a good question so we're working
with Koscheck send on some correctness
infrastructure that allows you to
basically proved that the generated code
and the original code are doing the same
thing or at least the the intermediate
results are correct so in terms of the
stencil stuff the correctness is more so
embedded in the domain knowledge so I
you know we're not doing formal
verification online for any of this
stuff but we have applied those
techniques that Koscheck son and his
students have come up with and actually
proved that that the stencil de sel is
outputting correct code
that's right just additional comment on
that some of the transformations that
are doing specific use a search tivity
and distributivity of to do the
transformations and that changes the
floating point properties so you don't
get exactly the same answer and
sometimes they can be very different and
there a lot of domain knowledge is
required to know which transformations
are okay so Jim pointed out that the
domain specific transformations we're
doing due to assume associativity in
commutativity and other properties of
floating points so they can change the
answer in terms of the floating point
correctness so that requires no having
domain knowledge of what things are okay
to do and what things are not okay to do
the last speaker for this session is
David Callahan David is a distinguished
engineer at Microsoft he has a PhD from
Rice University and he spent some time
at better computer Cray computer and
since joining microsoft he has been
working on parliament concurrency and
he's going to talk about his latest toy
c++ a MP good morning everyone thank you
for coming to redmond delighted to have
a chance to talk to you a little bit
about what we've been doing in visual
studio in parallel programming so
developer division has two broad
products one is visual studio that the
other is the dot net developer platform
and our broad mission is to make sure
the developers are successful targeting
windows platforms of which there are a
great variety for I'm sort of been at
Microsoft for 67 years now helping to
Shepard along the parallel programming
assets we made a big investment Visual
Studio 2010 around multi-core and
tomorrow I think we'll have a member of
my team come and talk both about that
and the extension work that we're
continuing on next one today I'm going
to talk about C++ accelerated massive
parallelism or C++ amp which is really
are offering to sir
tackle the problem of GPU program so let
me give you a little context here now we
know Moore's laws continues but the
hardware architects have been talking
about power power power power power for
years now and so sort of a natural
conclusion of that combination of cheap
transistors but can't turn them all on
is that we'll see specialization of
silicon to particular workloads and this
is sort of already somewhat pervasive in
a lot of places and one of the really
important workloads that exists is the
rendering workload manifested that's
today sort of handled by GPUs so this
combination factors have led to a really
fast evolution about what GPUs are and
where they're used so part of it is in
the program ability of their GPUs and
I'll start sort of six years ago when
Nvidia introduced c4 CUDA and said hey
you don't have to work in a graphics
framework to get the power of the GPU
available to you and once they made that
transition they're sort of put on this
path of making GPUs programmable like
CPUs in ways they never been before
subject of course the fact that graphics
is the workload that matters so they're
still dominated by engineering for that
workload three years after that came out
we saw that the execution model that was
sort of pioneered in CUDA then became
standardized both in opencl and indirect
Alexa 11 compute so the two major client
work stopper ating systems both embraced
this model and went forward with it as a
core capability along that same time of
course we saw the rise of mobile form
factors as a huge concern they embrace
this rich visual experience now coupled
with touch and that interactivity with
the visual experience is something
that's only delivered through a
specialized hardware solution an
integrated GPU in that solution space
Nvidia also built out special skews
saying hey this stuff will work in a
server environment as well and they'll
tackle the HPC market as aggressively as
they're attacking the mobile market at
the last GPU technology conference they
ran they
they had a factoid about the growth of
this at SC were in 2007 there was one
booth that talked about GPUs but last
year eighty percent of the booths were
talking about GPUs a big impact in the
HPC space and of course now you can go
rent those GPUs by the hour at Amazon
first and then other other places and
then the last step of this trend was the
embracing of moving these specialized
hardware capabilities on to the main CPU
die and building a composite
heterogeneous package AMD released their
eight first APU last year and the intel
Ivy Bridge which Intel's had graphics
accelerators as integrating parts for a
long time but this one is a dx11
compliant part and is really a candidate
for producing that the compute workload
that we're interested in so in this
context then we started investing about
how can we make this sort of emerging
sort of commodity platform a
heterogeneous platform assessable to a
very broad range of developers so that's
what we built in C++ accelerated massive
parallelism focus on data parallel
algorithms which are the part of the
sort of algorithm pattern space that are
most effectively optimized by these wide
new generation of vector processors we r
embrace the heterogeneous nature of the
computing so it's not just one kind of
processor but to you must deal with put
this in a mainstream context so put it
into C++ and give support in a major ide
like visual studio which will support
not just the language but also debugging
and profiling and get tools in the hands
of users that can use this effectively
for productivity and portability and
performance so balancing these three is
sort of the design challenge in the API
so this will be now part of Visual
Studio 2012 it's available in release
candidate now our approach to it was to
say hey this is just part of C++ so you
build a C++ app you include our amp
header suddenly you can be doing GPU
programming it's just sort of part of
the product not a special bolt-on add-on
and that goes all the way to
we think about acquiring the tools and
how you deploy the resulting
opportunities we do not think however of
this as a Microsoft Technology per se we
have a first implementation but we think
that this is the direction that the C++
community should move we created an open
specification for our API design and put
behind that the Microsoft community
promise which will it will guarantee a
royalty-free license to whatever IP you
need to implement the spec and we are
actively looking to have implementations
on linux on Android and Mac OS at its
core amp is just an STL library but
there's a couple of extensions to C++ we
made to actually enable targeting of the
diversified where that we're interested
in I will dig into those one of them is
a pretty novel extension the others at
week on sort of existing idea our
implementation is a layer on top of our
graphics platform support direct elect
x11 however directx11 doesn't shine
through so it's it should be feasible to
build an implementation on top of opencl
or even perhaps OpenGL we haven't done
that but our intention is not to make
DirectX shine through except in some
interop api's give you a very brief
introduction to the core concepts of
what is in C++ am starting with matrix
multiplication I'll do a very simple
implementation and later in the talk
I'll do a more sophisticated
implementation they'll give a more more
substantial performance advantage so
here's our our starting point us is
simple C++ version the usual textbook
three loops inner product in the
innermost loop the two outer loops are
then completely parallel the interface
starts with C++ stood vector types and
some explicit bounds passed in you know
one of the weaknesses of C++ as it
hasn't actually standardize on a
multi-dimensional data type which is
pretty important to do data parallel
programming with so one of the things
then we added in C++ app and this is an
essentially complete c plus
Plus amp program subject to missing on a
pH header and a namespace inclusion we
added a notion of an array view which
allows you to overlay onto an existing
linear data structure a
multi-dimensional view of that data and
so we do that for the the two input
vectors a and B there are flagged as
const we're not going to modify them and
the output vector C then we have a
library based parallel loop construct
which is actually very similar to what
we did for our task-based parallelism as
well and so this should be familiar to
users of our earlier work or intel's TBB
this parallel for each takes two
parameters one of them captures the
extent information of a parallel loop
nest so the the number of iterations in
each sort of dimension of the problem so
in this case that would be m and n and
then it takes a function closure which
in C++ is called a lambda and will
invoke that lambda once for every point
in the implied iteration space and
passing in an index vector to tell you
where you are in it so that's the core
data parallel paradigm of for every
point in this space do this function our
most significant addition to the
language is this restrict keyword which
defines could be applied to functions
and to lambda closures and it creates a
subset of C++ in the body of those
functions that subset is defines what is
legal to run on a GPU and it's also a
hook to the compiler to understand when
multiple implementations are necessary
I'll talk a little bit more about the
nature of restrictions later note that
the body of the inner loop is
essentially unchanged and we can pick
off the row column values out of the
index value the array views are also are
hooked understand if you're running in a
distributed distributed environment
where the GPU has its own memory what
needs to be copied over there and how
partly that's through what's captured in
the lambda it's also partly how we
marshal the arabia's over and i'll talk
a little bit more about that
as well now because we are running in a
potentially in a separate address based
potentially asynchronously to the CPU
there's also some API extensions here to
talk about what data if it needs to be
moved or doesn't so the discard data API
on see is an assertion hey the parallel
for each is just going to overwrite this
data so don't bother copying it over to
the GP if you need to treat the
underlying data as undefined and at the
bottom there's a synchronized which sort
of does the reverse saying hey this data
may have been modified on a GPU but I
want to store it back into its home
location in the CPU data structures
please do that now for me so this is now
an essentially complete c++ amp program
where most of the concepts we've
introduced are really kind of around the
array abstraction sort of the size of it
so it should be pretty straightforward
for most of our existing task-based
programmers to sort of understand this
and it's here which sort of gets to sort
of summer I'm sorry go ahead it doesn't
digital do all the blocking is necessary
to move it back and forth between CPU
so the question is if the data that is
accessed in the parallel Colonel doesn't
actually fit into the video memory
that's available in the card what
happens so in our first implementation
it's the responsibility of the developer
to ensure that happens so you'll get an
exception that if you exceed it there is
not enough information in general in the
API to allow us to automatically block
yes yes can you detect if the discard
data was plain incorrectly like so you
see after you said that you have any
checks so the question is are there any
checks in the system to verify that if
you put in and discard data incorrectly
and then use the stale data whether will
detect that we don't we don't do that in
the first first version so we have this
natural tension now between portability
and productivity on the one hand and the
performance and this will show up sort
of in how much of the machine do we let
shine through in the abstractions so we
know that sort of for portability and
productivity reasons you really want to
minimize the number of concepts that the
developers are exposed to represent an
increment over what they already know
this is just generally anytime a new
technology comes from the richer the set
of concepts the more trouble they'll
have to embrace it and you also need to
make sure that they know exactly when
it's a good idea to apply that and so
that leads us to focus fairly narrowly
on the patterns were applied to sort of
these data parallel constructs one good
composition with the host host
environment which is c++ and we've
achieved that by having a strong
integrated type system that spans both
classes of code and you also want to
sort of make sure that you pay attention
to the sort of the key patterns that
your developer will be facing and give
good application pattern support for
that so in this case we focus on the
parallel loop as the pattern we're
trying to make sure we have good support
in sort of the more general multi-core
space there's a there's lower level
support for tasking from which you could
build the patterns
but here we focus just on the pattern
itself on the performance side we are
faced with a lot of decisions about how
much memory hierarchy how many memory
alignment requirements what to do with
the exposed concurrency between the two
kinds of processors to have and how the
hardware scheduling mechanisms might get
exposed these are all areas where the
architecture is still considerably in
flux even today the range of GPUs are
fairly diverse and since we'd like to
have future proofing so that the codes
we write today run well on in a few
years as well it drives us to sort of
minimize the amount of hardware we
actually expose so I'd like to sort of
dig down into the bottom four of these
in the time I have left about sort of
some details of what what we're
attempting to achieve so let me start by
talking about the restrict amp function
qualifier so our implementation builds
on top of DirectX 11 which represented
sort of an industry standardization of
capability which is someone less than
what CPUs providing so there's a bunch
of rules about once you're sort of in
the GPU space what happens so you have
to kind of stay in the GPU space you
can't call back CPU functions most of
the GPU architectures actually don't
support either indirect functions or
function calls and so you have to carve
off a subset of the language which you
can fully in line and map to that more
limited capability there's typically no
memory management and very restrictive
pointed uses so these are things that if
you look at the most modern GPUs from
some of the leading companies have
already been relaxed and we would expect
over time to relax this list and we have
a strategy for them the other thing is
this restrict is part of the type system
so we currently have two notions of
restrict restrict amp for our GPU
targeting and restrict CPU for things
that just run on the CPU restrict CPU is
the default so if you don't say anything
that's what you get and you can have
overloads so you can tailor the
implementation of function to the
context that it's running in you can
also write functions that are guarantee
be by a design time to be safe to run in
either
action we anticipate there could be
other uses of restrict so we worked
really hard to make sure that it was
orthogonal to the rest of the system
maybe there's restrictions that
appropriate for CPU vector targets maybe
there's a notion of a pure function we'd
want to carve out so it's intended as a
general addition to C++ that we use to
enable heterogeneity we also worked with
some of our hardware partners to think
about what would be the evolution of
this set of restrictions over time if
you go read the open spec at the bottom
there's a road map there of likely big
buckets of how we might move from our
current amp amp one to an amp to which
would have a subset of this list so I've
already talked a little bit about a
review and its role of providing a
common name space between the CPU host
and the GPU the real function of it
however is to sort of provide copy as
needed semantics so here if my parallel
computation is running on a discrete
memory system then at the time that I
launched the colonel I can observe in
the in the Marshall glint in the lambda
what needs to be copied over and
subsequently if there's a reference on
the host I can do the appropriate
bookkeeping to say oh no the current
copies over the GPU I need to bring it
back on the other hand we know that
we're moving to an age where integrated
systems are will become the norm they'll
be able to share physical memory they'll
share caches eventually they'll show
cash protocols and so those copies will
become unnecessary and so we want to
make sure that we have a system that
allowed you to have to span that
transition so you can write to tolerate
a distributed memory environment that
will then light up and improve as on an
integrated system we also provide a
mechanism to explicitly allocate data on
a GPU so there's an array type that's
kind of analogous to a rave you but as a
storage container rather than just an
access method and so even today there's
a way to talk about place memory on the
GPU because there are scenarios in which
that makes sense
a more harder concept where we actually
start to say okay machines are not as
simple as we'd like them to be and they
kind of never have been but particularly
when you get to the memory hierarchy
there's a disconnect between how I want
to think about the machine and how it
really is and so we chose to embrace a
fairly simple extension which is hey
these machines they're multi-core and
every core has a cache and you have to
provide some mechanism to talk about
that locality within an otherwise data
parallel context so this is not a model
invented we inherited it from whether
the graphics guys were with the x11 but
it's a pretty good model spans a lot of
interesting case and is a compromise
because this part of architecture is
probably pretty stable I don't know what
the next stable point in in memory
hierarchy is likely to be so we
introduced within our data parallel
computation space the idea you can break
that space into tiles blocks of what the
pad were called them and these are sets
of iterations that are going to be
mapped to the same physical processor
now these physical processors are
typically vector processors so an
iteration in our space may actually map
to a lane and a vector processor not a
threat of its own but we will call it a
thread nonetheless once we have this
idea that a chunk of my space can map to
a physical processor we can allow
certain capabilities that tend to not
scale very well to be to shine through
and the particular ones are we introduce
a notion of barrier coordination so all
the threads in a tile all the threads on
a processor reach some point before they
any proceed and now we can introduce a
notion of shared storage there that is
suitable both for sort of temporal
caches we see on L on CPUs but also is
the scratchpad memories that are common
as software managed caches on GPS let me
go back to my matrix multiply remind you
that it's easy to do it in a block style
so you can take a block of
columns and a block of rows and then
accumulate them into a block of the
output so if the block of the output is
our tiling strategy for the data
parallelism and we can stage how we do
that rope block row column reduction
into it for example we guarantee that
bring in block 3 we multiply it against
block 3 and B and accumulate in the
output that those sub computations are
now things that can fit in a private
cache of a multiprocessor and so this
model we then can take forward into the
API design as here's matrix multiply in
the simple data parallel case that has
no manifest memory locality to exploit
and here's the variant of it where we do
introduce those things we introduce a
tile size in this case it's a static
constant the limitation of the v1 is it
must be a compile time constant we have
a variant of the parallel for each in
which you take the extent space and you
tile it based on these fixed sized
blocks so this is just an overloaded
parallel for each that it handles these
sort of tiled extents we changed the
parameter into the lambda instead of
taking an intent index it takes a tiled
index tiled index is a slightly larger
thing that has more a lot more
information related to what's going on
in a tiled context but we can still pick
off the sort of global index about where
you are in the original space and so
these two variants haven't made any
substantive change in the algorithm all
we've done is tile the iteration space
into blocks the more interesting change
then is how do we get to the locality
and that involves the following slide
where now we introduce a tile static
local variable so tile static is our
second language extension it's a new
storage class can only be used inside of
a tiled parallel for each and it allows
us to create little arrays which will be
mapped into the scratchpad memory of
GPUs or or would be fit into the l1
caches on a cpu now we take our
product loop we strip-mine it into
chunks so each chunk of that inner
product will load blocks from global
memory tuck them into the cache local
memory then when those loads are all
done it's done cooperatively every
thread in the tile does one data motion
we do a barrier to verify that all those
loads have settled then we can drop down
into the set of strip of chunks of the
inner product they now read out of cash
of protected and so the effect here is
that instead of every thread going to
memory for every array reference there's
a in this case sixteen fold reduction in
the in the global memory requirements
achieved through sort of this explicit
caching strategy and now a second
barrier protects the reeds in the inner
product from the rights from the next
iteration so this is how we've taken our
model of sort of l1 caches attached to
processors and put it into the API set
for the programming instruction yes you
what about a determinacy as the other
some reduce which could happen in any
order and you know in one issue
depending on Huffington and dynamically
scheduled is that you get to something
different we're getting different
answers so is there anything in your
language extensions that addresses that
listen so Jim's question is about how
deterministic is the programming model
and this particular example so this
particular example is actually
completely deterministic because the
output some is done the same way because
it's done by one thread and it's
actually done in the same order every
time the concurrency in this model is
between different tiles they are
completely unordered but between
different tiles in this model there's no
interactions a second question is is it
possible to introduce data races into
this model the answer is yes it is for
example if we dropped the second barrier
from here we would create a data race
between some threads reading finishing
their some reductions and then and other
threads starting to overwrite the shared
data
it's involved we actually have some
static analysis to detect those data
races and we and we can run in a mode in
which there's some dynamic analysis to
detect them as well but it's not
guaranteed to be a foolproof system so
in in deference the time I'm not going
to talk about our compilation deployment
model in depth we build sort of the
existing graphics infrastructure we ship
a fat binary we still have a final jit
to target that gives us the great
portability across different hardware's
both in the field now and over time it's
a it's a cumbersome model that can lead
to finger painting but it does give that
that core portability that's pretty
interesting so here are the two points I
tried to cover today we have a ton of
developer facing information about this
tool that's on the web there's a team
blog that you can get to by searching
for c++ amp in a nutshell or it's you
are heroes the bottom of the slide and
of course this all of this technology is
available in the release candidate so
you go download that today try it out
yourself see what you like any questions
more questions all right thank you